each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hi I'm modern Maserati from the software
reliability and research group and it's
my utmost pleasure today to introduce
mile or he's a research scientist at IBM
Haifa and he's been working in the area
of concurrency testing for a long time
now and he's the technical lead in the
area of coverage in IBM and is also an
IBM master inventor and he is actually
the general chair of the first high for
verification conference and he's been
the chair of the pat dad workshop for
like six seven years now 6m yeah and he
also teaches software testing in the
Technion and hifi University schmehl ok
thanks so so I know there are some
people here in the audience of the
experts and what I'm going to talk about
but I couldn't assume that for everybody
so i'll start with with things which are
more basic and i'm going to talk about
testing and debugging concurrent
software and this is related to work
which we have been doing in IBM since 99
and it started with the person who works
with me on the project I mean we were
two people but now a little bit bigger
when he got annoyed after trying for a
full half year to debug a single bug and
the problem was does it they could
recreate it back only once a month so it
made it harder to debug it so this is
one reason for the projects that we have
and the other reason for the project
that we had was it it was reaction to
the previous project actually another
group had was they were working on a
model based test generator what the idea
is that I write a model of the software
and then magically all sorts of really
good things will happen including
writing tests and finding expected
results and so forth and so on and they
actually did the
I did this project that they would drive
model based test generator and in
parallel to the traditional technique so
it's actually tested the same thing in
two different ways and it worked really
well but like almost any other model
based test generation project it failed
and there isn't it that it failed was
the testers didn't know how to use the
tool so it's a complicated tool to use
so what we were looking for at the time
was the tool that is under the hood in
the sense that it's possible that at
least one or two if you don't understand
how the engine in your car works but but
you can still drive them so we were
looking for the tool in which in which
the tester would not have to know how
the Tool Works or anything about it and
it would still be able to find bugs this
was the context in which this talk is
about so I'm going to explain why
concurrency testing is hard and I assume
that most of you will know some of it
that maybe some of it will be new to you
so the obvious thing is that when you
test the concurrent program you have in
determinism so sometimes it will fail
and sometimes it would succeed on the
same input so the fact that you haven't
tested you didn't find the bug does not
mean that this test will not find a bug
in the future the converse is also to
the fact that you run a test and you
didn't find the bug well not means it
somebody else will be able to it'll
happen again so you have two types of
problems here and most of them are
bosses am L very annoying so the first
one is the following you take your test
in run it as many times as you want
unusually fuel system is not complex
you'll get the same result somebody else
takes your test and on this the same
test many many times and it will get the
same result however it's not necessarily
the same result as yours so so what does
it mean it means that you have taken
this program and you have been testing
it for two years and you know you think
you've done a really good job and then
your customer takes it and runs it on
his new configuration and he finds the
bug
time he tested it and he says you know
you know you're not even trying so this
is annoying the second the second reason
that it cause its to be annoying is the
form the problem of reproducibility so
so you run the test and it assumes that
in tests you found the bug and then
somebody has to fix it right so you move
it to a system and the bug goes away and
it can fix it until you can find it so
let's assume if your car does not start
in the morning usually eventually you
can get it to start and you go to the
mechanic and you tell him fix it but it
starts really nicely because you've
driven it all the way there and now it's
warm so in my country if your mechanic
is willing to fix something that they
can't see happening this is not the
mechanic you want to go to you first
have to be able to to recreate the
problem so those are some of the issue
the next issue is that how good is your
testing how do you know how good is your
testing so let's assume that they take
your code and for the moment take my
word for it I remove all the
synchronization statement from your code
okay so yeah we have a tool that can do
that fall for java you can get it all
the desert full full C so funky the code
is still the same right I mean you just
remove all the synchronization let's
assume that you want the test and the
test give you the exact same result as
if you didn't have as before so what
does that mean it means that you're not
testing the synchronization at all right
if you can remove all the
synchronization and the test result will
stay the same it means that you're
testing is actually no good for
synchronization purposes and my guess is
that this is the case so I don't know
you have a really powerful environments
here but but you have to check the time
what I'm saying is correct maybe it's
not but how do you know which
synchronization did anything the
synchronization if nobody is trying to
actually get to the same place as a knob
how do you know if your test is is
getting there
so we talked about that and the result
is that our synchronizations in in our
big project in IBM that present on
average about ten percent of the bugs
that exists but a much larger percentage
of those that will actually make it to
the field because I'll very hard to find
in the beginning so so so it's not a
very large percentage of the value mean
10 is not small but but it's still a
high percentage of the bugs that the
customer found and and it's also one
which is much harder for for people to
fix using all sorts of of debugging
issues so I'm going to give an example
the fact that it in Java doesn't make a
difference in this case because it will
be the same in C so you have counter
plus plus and if you execute it what you
expect is for the counter to increase
right but but if it works in in in a
concurrent code you do two of them at
the same time so I can a plus pass is
actually implemented this slip byte
codes or will be implement the same way
in see you do a load and then an
increment but if you have a context
switch you do a load and then increment
and right back you get full right back
again you get full again okay so what
you did is you are you implemented it
you executed twice instead of getting
five you got for this is only part of
the problem the real problem is that one
of them is ignored all right so you
overwritten a result and you miss
something so just the fact that
something look like it is it is going to
be executing it once doesn't mean that
it's going to be doing that
okay so i'll give another example of i'm
going to start by giving example of bugs
so we have in a low world and i
apologize this this stock was not
written specifically for you so it's in
java i know that not all of you are
extremely familiar with java but but it
will be the same thing so we have two
two sides one of the mix to a execute
rights hello and that's one right
swelled and what happens in the mainland
is you start the hello sled and then you
do the world sled and then you go to
sleep print a new line so if you take
this totem and execute it you'll always
get hello world ok this is if this is
the only thing running in the system at
the time but what are they what are the
possibilities what can be the output of
this program what other output a
possible except hello world ok so when I
say start here what do I mean when I say
start here so who executes next so this
could be executing next or not so if it
doesn't execute next and this one
execute next then you get world and then
you get hello so what would actually
happen in your system I'm asking you
without knowing the answer linode answer
on some system when you just start for a
thread with the execution move to the
sled first or will it continue in the
main sleds so what I can tell you is it
depends on your the policy so in windows
and unix it's not the same actually and
in windows for java is deterministic and
in unix it's not ok so we can have a
word alone ok what else can you have
that's nice that's true so it's not it's
not atomic actually we could have first
age and then W and then oh and then he
okay yeah that's too what else can you
have you are okay so what we did here is
we wanted the new line to be at the end
of the program right and in order to
ensure that we did a slip statement
slips nine cents don't insure anything
okay so slip stagnant the only thing
that it actually ensures is it while
they sleep state so for a second this
this side is not executing this means
that the others are executing so you
could have a new line hello and then
world oh hello new line word or any
combination with the new line is one of
the cartel but ok so now the following
okay actually not waiting for the
children to pinch so this was an
interesting comment and it's actually
it's not true in Java but but it would
be too insane so what I'm was saying is
what happened if I had a new line and
then the main site finished what would
happen to those sleds and they are
called orphaned because her father is
dying but what will happen to them so in
some system like in peace sides I don't
know how it's in yours those will die as
well but in Java they don't we just stay
off from sled and in this case they
didn't need any data structures that
belong to the main sled which means are
doing fine on the loan so you could have
new line and then hello and then world
they won't die but what we have seen
just see now is that in order to poke
out program correctly in Concord you
have to actually know the definition of
of how everything is happening and most
people don't so you have all sorts of
interesting options here okay so up so
this little will be may be too difficult
the way it is because it's jeff specific
but but i'll ask you a few questions so
the first things that you really have to
understand is that synchronization and
to me city are not the same okay so when
you do when you have a lock nothing
becomes atomic as a result so for
example if you have extra space and you
put it in a lock that doesn't make it
atomic it just makes sure that not two
things can go into the same thing okay
so now you have the lock you have taken
a lock and then you have taken an
exception from inside the lock you go
out to some place with the exception
handler are you still hold in holding
that lock so the reason it's important
because if you are still holding the
lock it into the list it as part of your
exception handling and if you're not
holding the lock you don't need to
release it so
when the exception goes outside us in
facebook so your life the java the lock
is released what happens in your system
do you know in don't nap it's a list and
also in C so C actually doesn't have any
exception mechanism so a light show in
there is a structured exception handling
in Microsoft scene and is it a list of
everything well right so the ladder will
need to decide so they're not so is as
you have seen here is it in the place
that you program you need to know the
answer to this question if you don't
know the answer to this question you
don't know how to the exceptions
correctly and people some people believe
strongly nuts that nobody knows how to
the exception politely is that they say
that you should pull those exceptions
but but see I assume you all for coming
with exceptions then you should know the
answer to this question so now the
following question is is is so survive
another question which is the answer is
Java specific but you can think about it
in your own advantage so in the class
called conflict which is a synchronized
constructible conflict and inside that
is a method which has a synchronized
long if there is also a synchronized
method in this class and also static
synchronize method in this class and
also just regular middle which is all
Sigma license and the question is which
of those things can happen at the same
time so for example with a single as
method heal in a static synchronize
method here and when I am mg can
somebody else go into F okay so this is
the question and the actual question is
how they synchronized on the same object
because if they are synchronized on the
same object then once my slit is in here
it's protected and note the circuit not
going to
this place the answer is it's a non
synchronous machine working so we have
two different objects here one of them
is the class object which this is
synchronized on and this is synchronized
on which means that you can't do those
two in parallel and the other one is the
class instance object which those two
are synchronized on and you cannot go in
if you go into this you cannot go into
into this one again my guess is it not
everyone in the audience was the wave of
that and this is the kind of details
that you need to be aware of in order to
do those things correctly so I'm going
to give skip the next example except to
say that there are two bugs in this
program and when I made it in order to
give talks about it I found only one but
then it was fine because once I found
the second 1i turns into a feature
alright so now I can talk about it in
talks I was pretty happy I said you know
I'm a researcher at great bugs I find
them their features no problem there so
what could happen to a researcher is
that you publish something which is
wrong and when somebody else finds the
bug in your journal paper that's less
fun so so the claims that i have in this
I apologize for this really overloaded
slide it's there just to show that it's
part of a journal so my claim there is
that many people program with data races
intentionally and it's not always a bug
so I'll give you an example so let's
assume that you have a sign over the
road that give you the temperature and
you also have this thing's that measures
the temperature and what happens this
thing measure the temperature then it
does it a thousand times a second
because because that's the device that
you bought and you write it into this
buffer and this copies from the buffer
and and put it on the screen for the
people to see now people in general
don't care about the temperature
measured being a thousand times a second
does make any difference of them so once
that we say a minute is fine right
then what you doesn't change that fast
so so if I take it and I put it here and
I copy it to hear and as long as both
operations are atomic live the race
because I don't know which one of them
i'm copying but i don't care about it
because i don't care if i had the
temperature of the point nine nine seven
second order one point nine nine nine I
just don't care so I put it here and I
be spayed it every one minute and I'm
fine but let's assume that the following
problem occurs what I right here is 19
and 20 is because those are the
temperatures if it's not atomic maybe I
copy this and then I copy this and then
I could have a temperature like 10 right
because I copied the first the first
digit here in the second digit from this
one it's not atomic now this is bad it
doesn't have to be so if it was atomic
so if you tell if you say equals B is
this an atomic operation in in your
language do you know if it's an atomic
operation yeah like everything dancer is
maybe so it depends on what a and B is
so usually for like a show to an int it
will be atomic but if it's longer or
float and it's not and then so if you
have a equals B in two sleds running in
parallel you could have all sorts of
interesting results happening okay this
is why I said the database does not have
to be a bug and I gave an example well
what I do is I copy too I copied to
valuables and I copy them from once led
to another using a spin loop here in
which I wait to see that that I did part
of the copying then I did the end of the
copy and and I said this is fine this is
working this is not a bug and then
somebody told me well you forgot the
memory model of Java so how many people
are the well of the memory model in
which you work with and and why should
you care at all
okay so some people are the well and the
reasons that you should kill is actually
knew so so what happens in Java is it in
the theoretical implementation of the
language when you have a global variable
you have a local copy of that viable in
its led so when you change it dazzle
said do not necessarily see the changes
okay so if I like in one said this
global is equal to sleep and in another
said I'm living it I don't see that
there was a change I might see that
there was a change I mean it's very Lee
it's completely legal to do an
implementation in Java in which a sled
does not have a local copy and this was
the way it was done in the past now why
would you want to have a local copy for
each global viable why would you have
this feature of the language and the
reason is that most of your laptop's now
I think our dual core and will become be
having more calls in the future and if
you have a dual core computer then you'd
want to have the local value and not
copying it would actually make your
program faster this is fine except that
if you do a spin loop and you're
checking if some value was changing in
another sled you wouldn't know that it
change it really did change but you
don't know that because the global
variable was not copied so at this bag
and I couldn't find it in my machine but
but the people who wrote the paper could
find it another example of bugs let's
assume that you move money from one
account to another account the fact that
the two lines are one after that doesn't
mean that will be executed one of the
data so you have to be very careful and
it could be that between them you have a
shred switch and the amount may be
changing all the places the money goes
to will be changing this is not atomic
and making it synchronized will not make
it atomic either okay you have to be
very careful about it so let's assume
that it was atomic so let's assume that
I had
I had the idol situation in the bank
were like I do transfer funds from
account to account so I take money and I
move it from here to here and I move it
from here to here and the bank has this
assumption that the amount of money in
the bank will stay the same right so you
transfer between accounts and you assume
that the total amount will stay the same
let's assume that the transfer in the
stomach and what I go I do is I have
this loop that goes over the entire
money in the bank in checks that the
amount stays the same so what I do is I
summarize all the account and I check
the to stay the same way during this
time I might be transferring money will
the loop give me the correct result why
not you're saying no why wouldn't it
change when it is the sounds they could
have been looking
there's no synchronization I'm saying
let's assume that the changing of the
money is atomic so I'm moving money from
one to place to another and it's atomic
so this is yes other operations in a
comment it doesn't have a snapshot of
life I guess no operation so why is it
over it will get fun from first movie
money who fun to the prom okay so let's
assume that you started counting and you
got to heal and when you go to hear
somebody move money to heal and then you
continue then you counted this money
twice okay so the problem here is that
while this situation is correct the
observation of it is wrong which is a
very big problem by the way so for
example when you go into a cash machine
and you put you'll you'll card inside it
goes through right so why does it go so
one option is that it's counting money
but it's not another option is that it's
doing a transaction which it does
meh-meh' returns I mean it communicates
to another place but communication is
not usually that noisy so I do you know
why you have this noise when you put the
machine it's a it's a self-protection so
is this device whose job is to go move
because people are very upset when they
put the Cardinals I see nothing
happening and this could be very
dangerous to the machine right yeah
talking about boys it's just to prevent
people from like messing out pushing
more buttons and I feel about that for
fact image it's also good in people
that's that stood so so you want it to
be observed line sometimes when you have
a following its working it will have all
sorts of signs right so this is the
concurrency actually bugs are not
necessarily related to programming
related to problems which exist in the
real world and i'm going to show you
investigation report of a plane accident
which had to do if a concurrency bug
this is from the late 19th century not
so late actually but second half so the
problem is the following they started
having a training britain's and it
turned out that if train collides in the
middle of a tunnel it's really bad so
the first solution that they had was to
have two sets of tracks or if you go
this way you go on the right and if you
go this may possibly in England it's
that the way around but but you know
which direction you go to and you don't
have any more frontal collisions second
problem is that when you go into a train
and you hit each other in the back
that's also bad so what they have is
have this protocol with two people and
they are sending signals and we'll see
how it works so so the trains enter the
tunnel and also is a semaphore here and
this is why we have a semaphore and the
semaphore physically turns red so the
time runs it over any turns that this is
what it's supposed to do and in England
it sometimes will not work and when it
will not work it will usually be due to
the fact that it was freezing this is
extremely unlikely in Israel or I come
from but but in England it can happen so
so it's supposed to turn red and then
the signalman sends a note to dial
single men are saying that there is a
train in the tunnel
and then the train exit the tunnel and
you get a signal back and the signalman
physically turn on the semaphore to
green this is how this is supposed to
work the second option is turn red you
send a signal the second the second
train approaches the tunnel stops at the
red light by the way there is already a
bug here in the protocol so we have a
very short protocol here think about it
well we'll discuss it later there's
already a bug here at exit the tunnels
you get okay they said oh so I apologize
the bug is here the train into the
tunnel what happened was it the
semaphore failed to turn red right so
you send the notice there is somebody in
the tunnel and he lands outside turns it
to let himself and then he gets a signal
and everything is fine okay so all of
those is just to understand what the
protocol is about and now I'll show you
what really happened so the train enters
the town of the semaphore faced two
tonight he sends a notice there's a
train in the tunnel he's running but as
his running another plane enter the
tunnel so what was the back here the bag
was that running was a very first
priority thing to do but sending a
signal was not and he first send the
signal it's any time he should have done
it the other way around okay so we have
a second time in the towel he noticed
this guy running but he didn't succeed
in stopping so he knows something long
is going on the driver in the tunnel so
he actually guesses that there might be
a train ahead of him so he's worried
now the signalman sends another signal
to be now we are outside the protocol
right big got two signals and he didn't
see anything yet so something wrong is
going on and we have a third day okay so
we're in this not so good situation now
this driver doesn't know what's going on
so he stops in the middle of the tunnel
to think about it the first time I
enters the tunnel now what is B supposed
to do he got two signals and he sees one
train it sends a signal right now what
is a supposed to do a send two signals
and got back one what does the signals
that he got means so it seems that both
of them left the tunnel okay so it turns
it into green now this guy's that is
still suspicious he doesn't know what's
going on just so to be on the safe side
he decided to back up slowly out of the
tunnel and boom okay so there are many
concurrency issues that have to do with
the real world the real world problems
have concurrency in them it's not just
the program it's it's the real protocol
and to find this bug was this Firebug
was found by the customers right but
this could be expensive sometimes it's a
it's not the way you think so for
example are I was invited to give a talk
in odense livermore national
laboratories which is actually sometimes
helpful Israelis to get into because we
are not signed on the non-proliferation
treaty and I give the tokens are not
worried at all about bugs they just care
about performance okay custom what do
you do and they say we do a simulation
of atomic explosions okay and then you
think about it and and what's the
probability that the customer will
complain
right so you don't have customer
complaints you only less about quality
performance is important services let
other problems which was interesting so
you know one of the problems if you
don't usually need to solve is to detect
that a deadlock occurred if a deadlock
occurs you know it it deadlocked on you
but but when you run a system with
128,000 pasta sauce running concurrently
for a single application it could be
there is a deadlock for me a few
thousand of them and the problem is
still running so a deadlock is actually
a performance issue because it's running
slower so they have to do the deadlock
detection as the problem is running
which is usually not a problem for
others so so I assume that you know that
bugs could have different reasons as to
why is that important so really so so
there is the consequence for example if
somebody dies it's not a good bug to
have but but the other reasons such as
who found it so if your manager found it
it's semi bad and if somebody really
important found it it's really bad even
if the bug is not really important so
this bug was was important to us because
it was the first bug that we found the
power to on a little application which
is websphere so it was like an if
connection is not equal to null then do
this and with the reason is we don't
want a null pointer exception so what's
the bug here it's a fairly obvious one
okay so you could have a sled switch
here and then you can dedicate mal
pointer exception okay so this is one
bug there's another bug here which is
after the change here somebody change
connection to different connections and
then you stopped the whole connection so
it could be a security bug due to
concurrency because this is allowed to
do there the stop and others are not
allowed to do stuff but they can change
the connection and therefore they can
stop the bill own connection so we found
about 300 of them in the code now this
kind of bug can exist in the field for a
long time before somebody finds it
because for this bag to a care you need
a very very strict sled scheduling
sequence you need a set schedule to be
exactly here and then you need something
else to happen so once you know this
pattern you're not going to make it
anymore but if you don't know the spot
on this is this is okay an easy bug to
make
okay so that's an interesting question
so let's start with how we fix one so
now we know that so we have a bag here
so how do we fix this bug what's the
changing the codes that they have to
make
so if i create a lock here so i have a
lock here it's something to help me any
because that wasn't my problem to begin
with I can have a slide switch inside
inside the lock and then somebody else
change connection to now so the answer
is it locks do not have to do if codes
have to do with data so any place that I
touch connection I have to do a lock and
then I will lock all of them and this
will be fine this is do I actually fix
it but there is a lesson to learn here
so let's assume that you did that and
everything was fine and two years later
the new program L came into your project
and he didn't know about that so he
writes connection is equal to null in
this place which is very far away from
here and three months after you did that
you get a null pointer exceptions here
so who's to blame it will probably be
you if you are still yes
that you don't have atomicity all right
what you want is a domestic to hear ya
but but that means that the entire
project has to maintain the discipline
and that's the only way to do it in in
the following language that we have okay
so some typical back pattern so we talk
about atomicity right now so for example
this is not atomic even though it might
look a bit atomic to you as we said
equal may not be atomic to Paul to
instruction being right after the
assembly is not atomic you have to be
careful to stage lock is actually a very
common bug so the problem is that you
have two accesses and ZZ need to be
atomic so what you do is you make them
each right so you need to sort it is you
do lock on all the data start with
popular data structures but because you
don't want your lock to be very big you
don't do it in one lock and then you can
have a window in the middle which
changes it this is a this is a common
way for the data structure to get
co-opted that the lock is not fully
locked and database tools will not find
those things for you is also called high
level data races so an example will be
if you have if you are working let's
assume on on points any point has an x
and y coordinate so if in one function
that is it does something to X and
another function so that's something to
Y another function so that's something
to x and y and all of them are
synchronized right but but but if you
don't do them on the same look you do
something on x and y and in the middle
of something can happen to X all you do
something on x and y and then you do
something on X so you did something so
this was the first thing and then you
did that and then you do another one
like that before you did this one so we
have an inconsistent number
okay so we talked about this one slip
statements there's no going to the sleep
does everything as I said if you find a
sleeping the codes should be a very good
explanation to white sir if it has
something with customer experience this
is fine we don't want things to appear
too fast on the screen or so forth but
in general if you did that to make sure
that something happened by the time you
are done that's a bug so in Java we have
a notifying await the notifies are
synchronous so what happens if notify
happens before the wait it does nothing
so you have a notify ends any other wait
and you can wait for a fairly long time
how long do you think you can wait
if not if I will never happen how long
will you wait what we'll get back to
that question sir so blocking critical
section in a critical section you don't
want to block off on sleds this is again
depends on the implementation I don't
know I know how it is in Java I'm not
sure how it is in.net what happens when
you have an orphan sled in.net it does
it die or does it doesn't die so the
problem is that if you've uploaded if
they said it started it dies that also
does not die but it could be that some
of the data structures that it needs did
die so with it it won't do something
that decides it made it head it's not
there anymore and you could have
problems so unintentional difference wed
so sometimes when you have a good when
you have an API the API will start in
your sled so one thing that can happen
which is really annoying is if you have
the single solid program and it gets
into a deadlock
so a single solid program cannot get
into a deadlock in purely write this in
Java and C it good but but in Java it
cannot but what happen if you use a GUI
if you use a GUI your IP I creates a new
sled that you were not aware of and this
side may be competing with your sled on
the resources and you could have a
deadlock in the program that look single
sided now if one of the VP of your
company finds it which was the case for
us I me not for my code but for somebody
in my in phase two floors above me this
becomes an important bug and he said
well it can't be a deadlock it's a
single solid folga and there isn't a VP
could find it which nobody else did was
that he was the first one to have a dual
core machine so different timings we
talked about how you can get out of
weight this is the definition of the
language Java you can get out of weight
in five ways you can do a notify and
notify all the way it may be interrupted
you can have a timeout Oh in javas
there's something called the space wake
up which means that the machine decided
that you've waited enough and decided to
get out of it and the guarantee is that
this will readily occur in practice okay
this is part of the Java definition
parts as many polymers are not familiar
with which is why I had to put it here
in red because it didn't believe me and
what exception or no just wait something
yeah just the way it was called at the
time of driver right yes yes so timeout
is if you decide to have a time means
that you took an interrupt while you
were in the wait it's like taking an
interrupt waddling asleep you just get
out of it because of the adult
condition
this bait is for a conditional you wait
on an object so what it means that in
Java if a weight is not a while loop
it's a bug because you waited for some
reason and one if once you finished
waiting you have to check that this
isn't actually occurred there's no
guarantee that you are notified it's
actually to another languages as no
guarantees if you are notified because
you might have gotten the slim exception
and you want to check while you got out
but because of the space wake up this is
a bug oh no but you can saw an interrupt
okay another example of something that
so now I'm going to start talking about
a bit about testing we talked about bugs
so so let's assume that you want to test
the program and this program is supposed
to be sort of dependable which means
that it's running it's a distributive
program is running over the network and
the components are not dependable so the
network may not be reliable and itself
the components may die or not die but
the problem is to supposed to continue
to work gracefully so what you want it
to look if you're testing environment is
as if the network is not reliable the
problems that you have is the network
that you have in your testing
infrastructure is a really reliable one
okay and you know CPUs don't tend to die
on you so often so how would you test
the program this is the issue so one
solution is to have many students doing
that with the power that's an expensive
solution and they don't do it fast
enough usually a second option which we
had was when you have sockets you can in
the socket Intel seeds and decide what
happened to the messages and this would
look as if for example if you block the
messages it would look as if something
is not working currently so one thing
that we did here is you have a delay and
then means that the messages are going
away all not going away are delayed and
when you stop the delay sir will
continue so you have to know which which
behaviors are legal under your your
protocol so for example in tcp/ip you
know that the messages may be delayed
but they will arrive at the same order
in which they will send and they will
nothing else will happen to them in a
new DP AP you could have messages
arriving in a different order you could
have the messages arriving multiple
times and you have to make sure that
your
environment is he is happy with that and
that doesn't happen all that often in
the in a real environment ok so to
finish their this part of the talk so
what all those observations that we have
the first one is that slide switches do
not happen a lot so in javits on average
every 20,000 instructions unless
something else happens and and in many
bags you will not be able to see if you
do that so if you have a concurrent by
the probability that you will see it is
is low and usually the synchronization
statements that you have in the code you
have a few instructions here Noah Wyle
they know because you went in and the
only reason this will be not in the hope
is if somebody else tried to get in but
for that you need the sled switch and
you need somebody else to take control
and try to get in and this is unlikely
because usually this block is very small
so synchronization usually doesn't do
anything yes well it's more 24 single
core pasta sauce but that's still the
fact that this will be done very very
fast is to anyway yes multi call you'll
have more most things happening now the
second observation is it if you're
there's a problem I don't know what you
are doing as far as regular
programming's and you'll find out so if
you didn't do what the pho loop does you
know the program will not do what you
expect it to do but if you don't
understand what synchronization do
that's fine right because you will not
find this bug probably the customer will
but maybe by then you'll be in a
different project so so so if you don't
know the exact what this synchronization
means exactly then this is not going to
impact you immediately for example some
of you might not have known what happens
when you take an exception if you still
contain the lock or not contain a lot
but this is rare enough that in your
testing it will not happen it will
happen in somebody else's testing
this is one observation that's
observation is when you test it it's
almost deterministic in different in a
simple environment you have the tool
here chess with people are doing here to
find those kind of bugs but without the
tool you can run you poke them many many
times and you will not will not be able
to find the bugs but the fact that you
have not found the bug does not mean
that the customer will not find it the
first time it executes it ok so now I'm
going to talk about how we we go about
finding the bugs so we use something a
technique called the noise making and
what we do is when the program is
running we instrumented in all sorts of
places whose order may impact the result
and every time you get into our
instrumentation we might change the
timing so we might put a slip statement
or we yield or something else and that
means that whenever you execute the
program will try to cause different
interesting timings to happen and then
you can run the program the number of
times and hopefully nasty things will
happen now this is a dynamic technique
which does not assume that I know what
your program is supposed to do so I
don't give you warnings I told you this
my under the hood idea uhand the test
and i try to make the test fail but i
don't know what your test is supposed to
do so well this was the theory before we
encountered users but you know user
cause problems but but but the theory
was it you have a test and you run it
and we try to make it fail okay and if
it fails you know that it fail I don't
know what it's supposed to do and then
and then we'll help you debug it but you
just turn the center's the same way you
did before and everything is fine line
this is as I said this was this was the
tilly the first exception to this theory
was we assume as if you don't want
deadlox so if we detect the dedlock's
we're going to we're going to tell you
that is a potential deadlock and also we
have idea of what bugs look like so we
try to cause them to
happen but we don't report them so we
try to cause your program to behave in a
different way but you will tell us if
you're happy or not so if there is a
lifestyle example one time we'll put it
like that and one time we will put it
like that and if you're happy both ways
them it's fine with us this is this is
the tool and and there is no there's no
no idea of exhaustive et or anything we
just when you run the test so we try to
find mobiles oh we know when we'll get
that this is the packing so but but but
I'm talk about testing right now and we
are trying to cause the program to fail
but we don't know what Phil means
exactly so we look for back pattern so
for example if they say if there is a
wait and notify will try to cause the
Lost notify to happen so we'll try to
happen the notify happens before the
weight and then maybe I'll happy with
that but maybe it finds the bud if you
have a slip statement in your problem
we're likely to kill it just because we
don't like sleep statements but we could
also change its timing so the idea is
that you want to test usually you just
look in the dark we follow to you want
to test the number of times and you
might find that some of the darkest as
bugs in it as I said that this was the
idea before we hit the customers and
then they wanted features right so the
first feature had to do with deadlox and
I will get into it later but but the
first idea you should know about deadlox
is you should maintain lock discipline
so everybody here knows what lock
discipline is or let's ask if somebody
doesn't know what love discipline is I
get no waste hands either way so so
okay so when you have locks you might
take lock inside one inside the other so
you take lock a and then inside if you
take lock be right and if you do that
away in another slip maybe it took be an
inside it you took a and lock discipline
says that the order in which locks are
taking one inside the other should be
the same so here it's not the same and
if we look we get a graph who the F a
and B and it would be a cycle this is
the guff you really don't want to have
cycles in so you should know the order
of the locks in which you take things
and it should be this you should have
one order and you couldn't take it in
any other order it could be that it's
not a bug here because it could be that
for some reason those two slits cannot
run at the same time but it's still
really really not the way to program
this is something we're reporting will
report about also tied to cause to
happen we have orange box which comes
from the fact that the black box in an
airplane its color is orange and the
reason is it's much easier to see orange
than it is to see black so for example
let's assume that your program crashed
with a nullpointerexception what you
could do if in the orange box is ask
where did i get the value now so you
know that you had a null pointer at this
point but you don't know when it was
assigned so you look for the last few
values for the valuable and then letting
him do the orange box replay so every
bad and you want to rip late now for
reasons I don't have time to go into
replace a really really difficult
problem if you want to do it in a
reasonable amount of time but what we do
is we don't have replay but we what we
do is all noises using a random and we
start with a seed so when you run the
test again you can ask run the test the
same way you run it last time with the
same seed and if if everything else is
sort of the same then you are more
likely to see the bug again so for
very simple programs like the lowered it
will be deterministic and for large
programs we moved for 11 months to half
an hour is a debugging time but it still
was only one in 20 our program works as
I said it looks like that right so
certainly tell me you have your own code
and then you are hunting my code and you
have your own code and then you're
running my code so I know what your code
is doing all the time so have all sorts
of communication parameters and then you
can ask what is my code doing now well
is my code so let's a similar problem is
running on the server but it's running
like for an hour and you don't know what
it's doing then you can ask my contest
to open a socket and ask the socket
where is my program now what is it doing
right now and then you can tell you to
do something else maybe and then so
those are examples of some features that
the customers wanted another features
that the customer wanted was for example
not to see a specific bug now my code
does not have the concept of a specific
bug so it was difficult but but but the
use case was the following let's assume
that in testing I found the bug the
development didn't fix the code yet so
they're going to do it in two weeks and
I want to continue to test it but it
crashes on me all the time because I I
of this specific bug I already know
about this but I just don't want to see
it so what we did is where these
features that says you can give it a
method name or all the class name and
say until you see this class don't do
anything just basically start testing
only once this class is loaded I didn't
say that but you can for our program you
can do it it class load which means that
you don't have to instrument in the
beginning or you can instrument the
bytecode in any case you don't need to
compile again
we welcome the bytecode so anyway so
though two options one of them one of
them is we take the back code and
modified this is instrumenting offline
and the other one is it at class load so
when you cry when you load the class we
instrument we instrumented them the idea
of doing it at class there are
trade-offs so that's another's in which
you want to do one in the Arsenal's in
which you want to do data so for example
if you want to instrument the class if
you want to make changes to the way the
pull-down behaves for example you want
you find out that you don't like
something and you want to change it
which I'll show examples then you want
to do it if class load so so this is in
the middle of the execution if you want
to test many times you want to do it in
before that because it's more efficient
for you if you want to avoid system
classes okay so system classes are some
of them are protected which means Java
checks that you don't change them
because otherwise really bad things
happen that's one problem and the other
problem is that when you instrument the
class that would call other instrumented
classes you have a problem of recursion
so so the first problem I don't know how
to solve if a class is protected i'm not
going to instrument it because it won't
let me the second problem I mean for you
might be different but it's not my
classes so I can't do that the second
problem I do know how to do and I check
that if I'm seeing recursion happening I
just stop it in the middle okay so let's
assume that you have this you have this
thing going ooh Luongo those slides
before I'll get back to the two slides
so measuring concurrent coverage so
contest one of the features that context
does is they said in the introduction
I'm I will sort of all still in charge
of coverage in IBM so every thought that
I make has coverage in it doesn't have
to but it has
so contest measure our regular coverage
I mean you can use it to do statement
coverage and branch coverage in function
coverage and many people use it for that
because it's very convenient and one of
the features that people want me is to
have a feature that says don't find bugs
this was actually the features that
people want most out of contest in the
reason they wanted that is a rel people
whose job is to measure coverage this is
what they are told to do and if they run
the aggression in my finding bugs is on
then the radiation clashes you want the
test and some of them get into a
deadlock and some of them takes
exception so they can't measure the
calves allege we shouldn't measure
coverage on a tested fail but they don't
care if tests fail or not it's not their
job to job is to measure coverage so
they asked for this feature of cells
don't find bugs but if we leave this
point we're getting the synchronization
coverage synchronization coverage is
checking that every one of your
synchronization statement so fascination
statement it can do two things one is it
I was inside and somebody tried to get
in and I stopped him and the other one
is that I tried to get in and i will
stop because somebody else was in so
forever synchronization statements I
have to to sing the time trying to to do
block and blocked in if the
synchronization statement never did any
of them it never did anything so i want
to check whatever synchronization
statement Mike averages I have a single
assignment for every synchronization
snow it says did it do anything let's
try to do this or another placed one so
you need testing what do we do if you
need testing so suggestin for
concurrence unit testing is the
following you create test you apply our
tool to the code all the tools that you
have here and then you run the tests now
once you want to test if you find a bug
then go fix it if you find a deadlock go
fix it so let's assume that now you run
the tests that you have any lint find
bugs and you're happy with the results
so the next thing that you do is check
if you have good synchronization
coverage if
it's efficient you're done so if you
have a hundred percent synchronization
coverage every synchronizations and we
did something you're done you're testing
is we have the tools it will tell you
follow the synchronization if it was
covered or not which is what I said if
it actually did something hundred
percent every synchronization at least
once did something it's not very hard
actually but in practice it will be zero
before you start doing something now if
your synchronization coverage is not
good enough so it could be three reasons
so the first one is that your tests are
not good enough so for example we want
sigh we once came to IBM in in in basing
stock for those of you know basingstoke
is it's south of London and we wanted to
help her with with concurrency bugs and
they said we don't have a problem that's
it let's measure synchronization tablets
only measure and we get zero which is
not a very surprising number and then we
look at the tests and it turns out that
all the tests are single sided so you
can't get synchronization bug so explain
to them and they say AHA so we say ok
let's let's try try i mean i can't find
any races or dead logs with single-sided
tests so we fix it and they say they
have this and they run the test again
with with with multi loads and we go to
eat lunch which is a very short of
failing in England and then we go back
and they tell us we don't need you
anymore we have enough bugs you know all
right so one thing is that little tester
no no good that's one option so if you
need to like new tests and n-hexane one
the second one is that you haven't done
them enough times so it could be that
your tests came to find the
synchronization issue because you have
to to the two sides of executing and
they might get to the same place but
they didn't so you have contests which
might try to make it more common and you
learn it more times overnight and
hopefully you know you'll get better and
if you can get to
% with both of them it could be that
your design says it the synchronization
that cannot be executed so for example
if you have be inside of a and in every
path B is always inside of a you cannot
get you cannot get careful John be so
you have to find out one of the three
options and do something about them and
once you get one hundred percent you are
done as far as unit testing is concerned
and this is not a theoretical issue and
that does not say that sell not bugs
left but the experience is that we have
is it was the bugs left in the code
nobody else will ever find them which is
which is good enough right I mean you
always know that the code is basically
in all those lines between bugs so so
you have bugs are but but if you do that
we didn't we didn't find more bugs later
in this case you have to say is not
going to the case
for this program is what
you know to be a hundred percent all I
need is for every so so let's assume for
a together unless a tiny for every every
synchronization to at least once the two
slits try to get into it yeah okay so i
said as i said the third issue which
would say this is not done it's like a
statement that you cannot get into and
then it's your choice whether you'll
remove it all you say i want itself
because of future lessons or whatever
but what I can tell you is it it's
always inside another one so for example
if bill was always inside days and I
will be able to tell you that but if
something is not possible then I don't
know it's not it's not yeah everything
here is dynamic and I depend on on the
test actual tested him so in function
and system test what we tell you to do
this is die our regional idea is that
you run the tests the way you used to
run the test and hopefully you'll find
more bugs and we ask you to run detest
more times and we also tell you how good
the tests are so if you get
synchronization coverage or not and and
while you expect to get lower statement
coverage in system tests and you'd get
in unit tests in synchronization it's
not to you actually expect to get high
synchronization coverage and if you are
not doing it even with contest when with
the delays then you're not testing it
will enough also another expense is that
you will find the load problems with
less sleds because they have more more
connections we give you aids in
debugging and replace that we talked
about ok I don't know so to most things
that I wanted to show I'll start with
one which I thought was nice so let's
assume that they have the following
problem what I want to do I have the
test I sorry I have a program and every
test and what I know about the test is
it sometimes it fails and Samsung
sometimes it doesn't fail ok I have a
test it finds a bug it's a concurrency
bug what I want to show you
automatically is the exact line in the
code in which the buggies that's the
goal so I'm not trying to show you an
interleaving in which it fails i want to
tell you it's in 922 of this file so the
question is how do i go about doing that
and the idea is here the beginning of
the idea which was not good enough was
that I take the code and I instrument it
many times and every time I don't
instrumentation
on a subset of the points so i have
sleep points1 i do it on 11 i do it on
those two and so forth and so on i done
it many times in in time sometimes i
observed the bag and sometimes I don't
observe the bag so each points gets a
score which depends on how good it is in
finding the bug so if I instrument at
this point 50 times out of the hundred
runs in those 50 tiny it found the bug
the back happen when half the time then
it will get a score of point five and
for this one it happens a tenth of the
time it will get a score of point one
okay so i have a correlation here
between points and how good they are in
helping me find the bugs if i put a
noise in them and then the first thought
is that i will show you those high
points and those will be useful okay so
so if the bug is very sneaky like in
this program and i show you those hot
spots which are related to the values
and you look at them then then this is a
very good in finding the bug we have the
really strange problems though that
sometimes it's really easy to find the
bug so in testing if i dunno if it's
very easy to find the back so i'll give
you an example so let's assume that i
have two sleds and it says a equals four
and it says a closely and if the order
is it this one is first and this one is
second i find the bug ok but actually
usually when I would run it on one
machine this one would be first so what
do I need to do to find this bug what
would happen if i put a slip statement
here i will find the bug right because
then i will come here go here and then
when i finish here i will go back to it
if i put a slip statement here i will
also find it back and so forth and so on
so all those points will get high score
which is it doesn't know if you put it
here out here all of those points will
get high school which is the same high
school so what's my problem is is it
let's assume this one will go to score
five which is high as i show you this
point and you look at it and you don't
understand what I want because it's not
related to two other bag is so what I'm
going to do actually instead is instead
of looking at the score of a point I'm
going to look at the difference between
the point and the point after it in the
control flow of the program so all those
points will get sort of at five ish but
this one will get only one because it's
not related to the bug if you put a slip
statement here or not it doesn't make
any difference so the difference here
will be large in those points with the
large difference of the point that i'm
going to show to you so this is an
example of that i gave you how you write
the score course i have to realize that
you have to put it on the control flow
first and this is what it looks like in
the other problem and it shows some bugs
that we didn't see so actually I'm
running a bit over time so we do some
some more experimental things related to
healing and the idea is that we try to
make the bug so our technology in
general laws in order to make the bug
more likely to happen because this is
very useful interesting but of course in
the field you don't like that you'd like
to make it less likely to happen so one
of the things that we do is for example
if you have a deadlock and we find out
that you have a deadlock or potential
deadlock will hide it if you have the
race will find out so a race does not
mean so think about it here this does
not have necessarily to be a data race
for this problem to occur because if I'd
synchronization I would still I would
still have the same problem so I care
about the order in which those things
happen even though so a synchronization
so if I find the others that I don't
like I will try to make it i'll try to
make them behave only in the order that
i like if i find things that should be
atomic and they are not atomic i'll try
to make them behave as if the atomic in
the field this is only the reasonable
idea to do when when it's when it makes
sense to hear more than two
you to fix so many times it will be much
better if you can actually fix it but
sometimes you don't have access to a
program and you want to make sure that
if the program fails it can sort of fix
itself this for a while have noise
in the production so they don't but when
they tell me that they are happy I'm
happy with what's happening then i'm
going to introduce it and fix it this is
why I said I scenarios in which you
wanting to reduce noise in the middle so
so if I'm so so so that as long as the
problem is running fine I'm not doing
anything once it's not running fine then
I will I will fix it i will i will
analyze it and fix it and every single
he kind of noise that you introduce you
it's very time it yes is there anything
else there well you can use the white
statements and and you can also change
values if you want but changing values
very risky way will depend how much
sleep
not camping so I have cut off an owl and
I don't want to introduce the next
subject because then it will be no time
for questions we have wave waves which
we are talking with modern hear about
about the dedlock's which is how we
actually we actually find them and
what's special about the way we do it is
we do it we collect the information from
a number of lands usually people did it
from a single large because you need to
know the object and we and the objects
are depending on the execution when you
run it again it will be a different
object so you don't know how to
associate it but you have a different
way to do it but i think i'll stop here
and i'll be happy to have any questions
interested in knowing more about what is
best if you do
okay so we have a project the European
project yeah it's something with the
tool does so I'll give a few examples
but first it's part of a European
project called shadows which is about
healing programs on the run so so let's
assume that they found this thing a and
B in bna where it was running so one
thing that I can introduce is they can
use introduced something called the gate
lock so I found out there's a cycling
its component today and bill or whatever
AB&C and before you take a and B I will
take it I will take a look hold a B and
when you list them i will release this
lock okay so if I do that I no longer
have this this deadlock however if if I
did if I did that and and then I had
this in situation which is not a
deadlock after introduce it I have a new
deadlock so I have to make sure that
once I solve one problem I didn't cause
another it actually can get complicated
ok so this something that we do in 444
deadlock full photo Mississippi willing
to these new locks that try to project
specific data structures so we don't see
specific types of races if there are
races it's all orders which you know we
like we've seen it with this order it
works and with this one it doesn't we'll
turn it into this delays it cause one of
them to happen which is not fixing the
bug properly but it's it's on the best
effort we do another sort of interesting
things for performance for healing
performance problems so
this is a yeah this is hell performance
so the following thing is to to fix
performance program so let's assume that
you have a client-server and this is
request and this is how many oh glad and
this is the time period so usually the
graph would look something like that in
the beginning the molle quest you have
the more you can't and then and then you
which the stage in the system will he
doesn't handle any more requests nicely
I mean the system was not designed well
then something like that will happen you
ask Molly quest but you get less of them
you get less granted so assume that you
have the silver and you have clients and
as long as you have less than 10,000
clients you are fine but but once you
have more than Z ask for more things and
things get bad so we have a component
that analyze this picture and if the
picture looks like that what I want to
do is I want it to get it to look like
that and the way I do it is I will slow
down the clients so slowing down is
really easy right I just instruments
them on the fly and I start slowing them
down but the result is that they get the
service faster so I slowed them down and
entire the entire system is now running
faster because I remove this behavior
here they also bugs that you can heal
this way so for example let's assume
that there is this buffer and if you
have 300 request with something wrong
happening and we recognize it when the
number of outstanding requests is bigger
than see how that something nasty will
happen then will not let it get to that
number by slowing down there
oh so what they did is somebody else's
did a performance analysis of the system
as it is running and it got to be the
fair initially this picture is happening
this is the picture now he tells me he
saw that we have healing agent in and
saying so he tells me slow down I don't
when I get to hear it tells me slow down
so I slowed down a bit so if he told me
slow down too much
right but it's actually two different
components so usually other performance
component that will look at what the
system is doing in general and then if
the system is behaving this way then i
will just I want to erase this part of
the graph I don't like it and by slowing
it down you make the system and pasta
which is maybe counterintuitive this is
if the scoring system that you said 10
years and loss ever so for detecting
cases we actually utilize the table for
detecting races we use our own recipe if
you ask it usually we don't so the tool
is an open architecture above which you
can you can write anything that you want
as a listener and somebody else load the
race detector University in the know and
and we can use that and in putting a lot
of noises sometimes bad not necessary
for performance but you find less of the
bugs so so think about you have water
falling right so the problem is like
this water falling and if you introduce
delays lots of delays then the intense
the entire picture would look very
similar to what it was to begin with
because into these lots of delays but if
you introduce few delays you stop here
and here than the entire picture will
start looking different in you'll expose
more bugs so it turns out that some of
the delays will hide the pipes many
delays can hide the bugs and you don't
want to have them so if you can know
where to put a few delays this is good
so one of the things that we do in the
beginning for example is find out which
valuables are actually touched by more
than once read and then we'll put delay
maybe only on those any yes question a
little process so is it mandatory for
you
developers and testers it may naturally
use it so it's not matter though as i
said i was talking to Madden so IBM is a
very distributive company it's like like
many many different places and and it's
not we can't mandate anything to anybody
the people the people we work with it's
been used in both both way developers
and by oh and i forgot to say 11 more
important thing which tom is probably
wondering why I didn't say it yet so we
actually teach the views as well we
teach how to the view this is yes and
that's one of the major things that we
do but we started it by teaching people
how to live you can for concurrency
problems so the problem is that regular
the view will look at the single out
effect and the back maybe due to the
fact that you have a number of artifacts
so it's really hard to find content bugs
so when we do a concurrent with you are
one of the things we teach a hole called
the devil's advocate so you walk over
the code into this guy saying okay now
we switch in cell walls as to why you'd
want to switch now for example if you
see an if statement and then a
synchronization start yeah that's a good
place to have a sled switch and see if
something bad can happen okay so so have
this wall and then you don't have to
actually I mean you do it by hand so it
can't go so many inter livings but
usually you find lots of things so we
teach to developers how to do the views
for concurrency both using the bug
patterns and the interleaving the vo
technique and and then how to use the
tools and for system test tells it's
fairly easy very straightforward to
properly etc so how are you have one
percentage of
consumer plus do you catch with the
process and at all
well they said before if you do any
testing properly we haven't seen badly
found later concurrency but so this is
what some of the products you did it for
example in storage but you really don't
want to see those bugs but so nothing's
is they don't exist they surely exist
but you get it to be clean enough in
unit testing that you don't find it
later okay so thanks a lot